[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
imaginez un village en brousse
les enfants jouent devant les cases les
parents son champ le soir à la veillée
on se retrouve pour la palabre la vie
s'écoule paisiblement
puis un beau matin débarquent des grands
gaillards avec un fort accent
anglo-saxon des chemises jaunes orange
bandes réfléchissantes talkie walkie
casques des instruments un peu bizarres
des gros 4 4 les mineurs et ils se
mettent à creuser un peu partout ça dure
quelques semaines puis quelques mois
plus tard le cned président de la
république de notre pays fait des belles
annonces nous avons dans notre sous sol
de notre cher pays du niobium du tantale
de l'uranium avec cette richesse nous
allons être sur la voie de l'émergence
nous allons faire des infrastructures
demain sera meilleur
alors vous vous dites c'est formidable
moi je vais pour avoir du travail
je vais pouvoir envoyer mes enfants à
l'université je vais pouvoir m'acheter
un véhicule améliorer ma maison
et puis les premiers employés arrivent
des australiens des canadiens des sud
africains des nationaux mais de la
capitale et quand vous vous allez au
guichet dans bausch on vous dit ah mais
toi tu n'as pas de formation tu connais
pas notre métier tu peux pas travailler
avec nous et là vous contemplez tout ça
vous voyez les camions qui passent et
comme me disait un vieux dans une mine
au gabon sur lequel j'avais travaillé
l'argent passe
et oui malheureusement dans ces grands
projets c'est souvent la réalité pour
les populations locales
l'argent passe alors on fait quoi on
s'en contente
après tout on paye nos impôts non dans
notre monde d'aujourd'hui il faut faire
du social faut faire des choses alors on
donne de l'argent au club de foot
la case de santé à l'école c'est mieux
mais qu'est ce qui se passe le jour on
va partir parce que le puits de pétrole
il va s'assécher un jour il y en aura
plus l'ami n'y aura plus de minerai ce
sera fini un jour où toutes ces
subventions n'y en aura plus
est-ce qu'on va s'arrêter est ce qu'on
peut se sont contentés alors moi je vous
dis et si on investissait oui je répète
et si on investissait vous allez me dire
parle d'investissements pour aider les
populations locales
mais réfléchissons un peu c'est quoi un
investissement quand on investit on crée
des emplois créés des emplois directs on
a des employés créent des emplois
indirects
on a des sous traitants on a des
fournisseurs ces gens ont des employés
ses sous traitants et ses fournisseurs
ont eux mêmes des employés etc etc
ça crée de l'argent du cou qui circulent
cet argent est utilisé pour acheter des
biens des services pour investir et
avoir des employés etc sont des taxes
des impôts qui sont payés qui sont
utilisés par les pouvoirs publics pour
avoir des écoles des centres de santé
des infrastructures
enfin une entreprise ça se projette dans
l'avenir ça pense à demain donc ça
investit toujours et toujours et
toujours
alors petite parenthèse quand je parle
d'investissements et d'entrepreneurs je
parle des entrepreneurs non prédateur
mais des entrepreneurs qui ont le sens
du bien commun le sens de la communauté
aussi le sens de l'autre et mais
globalement je sillonne beaucoup
l'afrique je rencontre énormément
d'entrepreneurs notamment en afrique et
la majorité de ces entrepreneurs ont le
sens de la responsabilité vis-à-vis de
la société
il ya une grande étude qui était faite
par un grand cabinet qui démontrait que
96 %
des entrepreneurs et chefs d'entreprise
en afrique considère que le
développement durable que la communauté
est important voire très important
fermez la parenthèse alors après 15 ans
d'expérience professionnelle dans une
ong un grand groupe international de pme
en france en amérique du sud et en
afrique
je me suis dit qu'il y avait quelque
chose à faire et que le développement
n'était pas là que l'apanage des ong des
grandes institutions internationales
mais que là aussi là dedans les
entreprises avec quelque chose à dire
et donc j'ai fondé une entreprise
s'appelle classe m avec mon associé
notre métier c'est d'accompagner les
grands groupes industriels dans le
développement d'activités économiques au
plus proche de leurs installations afin
de créer de l'emploi et l'économie pour
les populations locales
je vous donne un exemple on a travaillé
sur une mine au gabon où paradoxalement
la cantine n'achetaient pas ses produits
auprès des villages environnants
pourquoi parce que malheureusement les
gens n'étaient pas organisés en
coopératives
il avait du mal à fournir des volumes
demandés pas de traçabilité non quid de
la sécurité alimentaire et surtout il
était dans l'informel totale qu'on
imagine mal le chef de cuisine au petit
matin prendre son pick-up aller dans les
villages acheter un régime de même par
ci du manioc par là ça marchait pas et
donc ont affronté on a monté une
centrale d'achat qui travaille avec ses
villages pour dans un premier temps
fournir la cantine du site
et comme c'est une entreprise on a été
chercher des marchés par ailleurs et
l'entreprise s'est développée
petit à petit et aujourd'hui cinq ans
après sa création le site minier en tant
que tel lui a fermé le projet s'est
arrêté et l'entreprise
elle continue elle a aujourd'hui plus de
100 salariés et travaille avec 808 sens
paysan dans son environnement et en
quatre ans c'est presque 7 milliards de
francs cfa de chiffre d'affaires qui ont
été dépensés dans la région est
réinvesti dans
deuxième exemple avec un groupe minier
là aussi on dévore qui est notamment
basée ici à abidjan
on investit dans des projets autour de
chacun de leurs sites
on a fait récemment un investissement au
mali dans la première usine de karité du
mali jusqu'à aujourd'hui beaucoup de
karité au mali le karité les noix sont
exportés alors pourquoi on fait investir
denys millet dans une usine de karité
bas simplement parce que l'arbre à
karité pousse dans la zone où eux ont
leur opération donc investir dans cette
cuisine on parle de 30 mille tonnes
petits projets investir dans cette usine
c'est avoir un appel une demande très
importante de noah et ses noix sont
traditionnellement ramassés par les
femmes des communautés
donc cette demande génère en fête du
travail pour ses bêtes dans ces
personnes et pour les communautés qui
sont autour du site
donc elles bénéficient de manière
indirecte de l'investissement qui
industriel qui a été fait sur le site
et deuxièmement c'est fondamental pour
le pays ça participe à l'économie du
pays puisque la valeur secret beaucoup
plus dans la transformation
pendant juste le ramassage et l'envoi
des noix donc on a un peu une usine en
fait qui produit et qui transforme qui
créent de la richesse dans le pays
donc on voit bien que c'est en créant la
rente habitants créant de la rentabilité
on crée de la durabilité
on peut dire ce qui est rentable et
durable en effet on a un intérêt à agir
cet intérêt peut être financier peut
être aussi extra financiers et on se
rend compte que on se peut se projeter
ainsi dans l'avenir les projets
subventionnés eux il s'arrête un jour ou
l'autre les investissements ils
continuent alors pas de naïveté
ça peut faire faillite aussi mais la
tendance est plus à la continuation
non vraiment la rentabilité c'est un
élément clé de la durabilité pour ses
projets je crois beaucoup en la vertu de
la pme comme vecteur de développement
dans la pme on a le chef d'entreprise
qui est impliqué totalement c'est son
bébé et c'est son petit très souvent ces
équipes sont avec lui c'est aussi leurs
petits
il ya pas de rock rassis c'est efficace
ça avance vite et ça permet cette
agilité qui est nécessaire pour coller
au plus près des réalités locales alors
c'est pas facile en afrique c'est
particulièrement difficile il ya des
problèmes liés aux infrastructures
il ya des problèmes liés au financement
c'est difficile de financer l'apn en
afrique les problèmes de corruption et
des problèmes de la concurrence de
l'informel donc c'est vrai que les
entrepreneurs en afrique sont des héros
ça il faut se le dire mais hélas pme par
ailleurs elle permet aussi de coller
vraiment à la réalité locale et ne pas
imaginer des projets trop grand
surdimensionné dans lesquels on va
engloutir des millions de dollars et qui
au final ne donne rien enfin c'est
important dans ce type de projet de ne
pas plaquer des idées toutes faites
on est très forts souvent pour importer
une idée et se dira voilà ça marchait là
ça va marcher ça va marcher à cet
endroit
non il faut vraiment avoir des projets
qu'ils soient totalement adapté à la
réalité locale
alors vous allez me dire c'est très bien
tout ça mais à quoi ça sert
on me l'a déjà dit un patron
opérationnel d'un groupe industriel qui
m'a dit non mais t'es gentil tu vas me
faire dépenser un million de dollars
dans une usine de karité mois avec un
million de dollar j'achète un jumper
c'est assez énorme camion avec des roues
qui ont 4 mètres de diamètre
ça ça lui parle aux gars et ben en fait
c'est extrêmement rentable pour lui on
va pourquoi d'abord ce type de projet
permet d'avoir des relations apaisées
avec les populations locales
on ne mord pas la main qui vous donne du
travail donc avoir une pme une
entreprise qui donne du travail ou plus
grand nombre ça permet aux populations
de profiter de l'investissement
je connais un cas d'une usine où il y
avait des mauvaises relations avec les
populations locales
elles ont envahi le site
commencé à casser les choses dans les
bureaux dans des ateliers
ça a coûté presque 5 milliards de francs
cfa avec 5 milliards j'investis dans
deux usines de qualité deuxièmement si
votre produit est un produit de grand
public est une marque c'est important de
d'envoyer une image positive de votre
marque
on a tous en tête la tragédie qui a eu
au bangladesh quand de cet immeuble où
travailler des sous-traitants de marque
de vêtements européen cet immeuble qui
s'est effondré et qui fait des centaines
de morts ça a eu un effet désastreux sur
l'image de marque de ces entreprises là
et donc a contrario travailler de
manière positive positive avec les
populations renforce l'image de marque
de son entreprise
troisièmement ça permet d'avoir des
bonnes relations avec les autorités
locales dans les grands projets
industriels ça se traite au niveau des
nationales et les autorités locales en
général n'ont que les problèmes à gérer
le fait d'investir dans des projets de
créer de l'emploi de créer de la valeur
localement ça permet d'avoir des
relations beaucoup plus apaisé beaucoup
plus positive avec ces autorités locales
c'est bon pour les investisseurs tous
ces projets ne sont pas sans argent et
c'est beaucoup d'argent
cet argent vient des fonds
d'investissement derrière ces fonds
d'investissement
c'est vous c'est moi sont des économies
aujourd'hui on est dans un monde de
l'information
on veut savoir ce qui se passe et on
sait ce qui se passe et on veut que
notre argent ils soient bien utilisés on
n'a pas envie de financer que notre
argent serve à financer des mauvais
projet on veut que ça finances des baux
pour des bons projets ça c'est un impact
considérable sur des projets industriels
je vois quelques regard dubitatif je
vous promets aléas indaba en afrique du
sud au mois de février il ya tous les
ans la grande messe du monde minier et
on ne parle que de développement
économique que de développement durable
pourquoi parce que les investisseurs
derrière pouce pour ça parce que c'est
important pour eux c'est aussi
excellent pour le management quand vous
êtes un cadre un agent de maîtrise un
employé d'une entreprise vertueuses qui
fait bien autour d'elle qui participent
au développement économique de la région
dont vous vivez souvent de la région
dont vous êtes originaire eh ben ça
donne envie
ça donne envie de se donner pour
l'entreprise ça donne envie d'aller de
l'avant
et donc c'est extrêmement positif pour
les salariés extrêmement positif pour le
travail au sein d'entreprises
enfin c'est bon dans les relations avec
le gouvernement central le gouvernement
du pays
non seulement on investit dans son
business
celui pour lequel on vient mais en plus
on participe au développement général du
pays au développement économique du pays
en sortant de l'habituel scolaire santé
et qui finalement est le rôle de l'état
et les tâches désir l'assumer et donc on
est ainsi un co développeur de du pays
et ça c'est extrêmement bon et c'est
extrêmement bon dans cette relation
qu'on peut avoir avec les pouvoirs
centraux pour dent dans ce qu'on appelle
la license to operate
cette licence eu droit à opérer et donc
se soucier du développement économique
local
voyez on voit c'est extrêmement vertueux
c'est bon pour les populations
et c'est aussi bon pour l'industriel moi
je dirais il faut pas se priver
il faut vraiment pas se priver il faut
le faire et vous les entrepreneurs ce
qu'il ya beaucoup d'entrepreneurs aller
voir les industriels titiller les
démontrer leur que c'est leur intérêt
d'investir dans vos business d'investir
dans vos activités
elle est lyon a gagné comme vous vous y
avait à gagner et donc moi j'ai un voeu
où je dirais même un rêve ce serait que
chaque industriels comprennent son
intérêt comprennent pourquoi il faut
qu'il participe au développement
économique local
j'aimerais que chaque industriel investi
dans un projet autour de son site un
projet de pme locales
et qu'avec l'argent qui retire de ce
projet ils investissent dans un deuxième
projet et ainsi de suite
et de cette manière par le travail par
le courage par l'engagement on
participera à la création d'un monde
meilleur
d'un monde durable je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]